Now let me give you an example.
If suppose a father dies and after
giving the shares of all the other
relatives he has one son one daughter
and he has $150,000
remaining.
So to the son he will in inherit
$100,000
and the daughter she will inherit
$50,000.
Now when the son inherits $100,000 US
he'll have to look after his wife his
children
maybe he will spend $80,000 looking
after the wife and the children and the
other relatives who come under his care
but the woman when she inates $50,000
she need not spend a single dollar on
anyone
if she wants to do voluntary is
different she need NOT SO I'M ASKING YOU
A QUESTION WOULD YOU PREFER prefer
inating $100,000 and spending $80,000 on
somebody else or would you prefer
inating $50,000 and keeping everything
for yourself? Which is better? Which is
better? First or second?
First or second? Second. Mashallah. So
we are disadvantage.
Imagine if Allah said both gets equal
then we would say this is injustice. You
lay shoulder on you burden on the
shoulder. We are we have to look after
our wives after children maybe our
parents and you give same equal share.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is least is
unjust in the least degree. Surah nah
verse 40. So that is the reason in Islam
because Allah is just and the financial
burden is not laid on the shoulder of
the woman. The women inherit half of
that of the male counterpart but yet
financially they are more secured.
The 17th
most common question asked by the non
asked by the non-Muslim regarding Islam
is that when Islam is such a logical
religion,
how do you believe in life after death?
How can you prove the existence of life
after death? And the reply to this
question I say that if you analyze the
Quran there are 6,236
verses in the Quran. Out of this more
than a thousand speak about science and
if you put the Quran to the test of
science established science we come to
know hypothetically that 80% of the
Quran
has been proved to be 100% correct. 20%
may go in the ambiguous slot unknown
neither right neither wrong because
science has in advance so far to prove
every verse of the Quran maybe 50 years
later 100 years later 200 years later
we'll come to know but my logic says
when 80% of the Quran has been proved to
be 100% correct not even.1% wrong and
the balanced 20% is ambiguous neither
Neither neither wrong. No one can prove
even.1% wrong. So my logic says when 80%
is 100% correct and proved to be
scientifically correct and 20% is
ambiguous unknown. My logic says that
even this 20% will be correct. So when
the Quran says there is life after
death, it is not a blind belief. IT'S A
LOGICAL BELIEF. IT'S A scientific
belief. Today science has an advance
to prove their life after death. Quran
says there life after death. Quran says
in surah mo chapter number 6 verse
number two
it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you is good
indeeds. That means this life is a test
for you. He has created death first.
Allah creates death then Allah creates
life to test which of you is good
indeed. SO THIS LIFE IS A TEST FOR US
FOR THE AKAR.
So Quran says the life after death
science has improved it. I agree with
you. Science hasn't proved about jin.
Science hasn't proved about angel. So my
logic says when 80% is 100% correct and
the balance 20% is ambiguous, neither
right or wrong. My logic says inshallah
this 20% which is ambiguous also will be
100% correct. Now today
let us try to piv logically about the
concept of life after death.